[Music]  things got ugly when you were away I  asked myself every day what you would do  if you were here  penny bothered you figure she's the one  who greased my wheels  I did a job for what kind of job it's a  one-time thing  forget it best not to ask him any  questions we're squared away sure good  you know when I was 16 my old man kicked  me out told me to go to hell instead I  joined the serpents and then the army  and then back again I don't want that  life from your joke I want you to go to  college get out of this godforsaken town  I ran the gauntlet I fought with the  Serpent's and for them I have to stay  I want to stay but I need your blessing  just promise me you'll keep writing and  will I do everyday  [Music]  Riverdale all-new episode tonight at  8:00 7:00 central only on the CW and the  CW app  [Music]